ghislaine merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france alors c'est ces derniers mois le
portugal était cité en exemple dans sa
gestion de la pide mire
aujourd'hui on le disait le pays est
submergé qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé
finalement si finalement noël a été
jusqu'à 2h du mat
on dit que nouvel an ils ont vraiment
fermé était sévère mais depuis peu qui
ponctuent l'épidémie a pris monsieur
chat en chicon guiche c'est vrai
aujourd'hui à lisbonne on a une
situation absolument terry la pio précis
une situation absolument terrible ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
hôpitaux sont totalement saturés ça veut
dire qu'il manque du matériel ça veut
dire qu'il n'ya plus de masques telle
est la situation la situation au
portugal à lisbonne aujourd'hui et lutte
libre les rues sont vides les magasins
sont vides et a presque personne dedans
y'a un atmosphère respectueuse tout le
monde reconnaît le oui c'est dangereux
il faut faire attention
heureusement ça se passe comme ça mais
le pire c'était quand les ambulances ont
commencé à hurler
ils ont rester là car en ambulance
devant l'hôpital salmaniya notre jour ça
faisait mal
profondément dedans d'entendre ces gens
qui sont en train de mourir dans les
ambulances ne peuvent pas rentrer dans
les hôpitaux
oui ça c'était la semaine dernière alors
en plus oui oui je vous en prie en plus
il ya eu les élections présidentielles
ce qu'il ya eu le confinement de puits
avant nouvel an
mais finalement c'est vers sévère mais
finalement il y avait les élections il
fallait que tout le monde sorte pour
voter oui la vie politique d'
importantes on est tout à fait d'accord
mais finalement peut-être été mieux de
faire ça à distance ou d'une autre
manière pour pas trop bousculer les
mouvements sociaux il est critiqué
aujourd'hui ce scrutin par la population
par la presse locale
ces scrutins le scrutin présidentiel le
fait que les portugais soit sorti pour
aller voter est ce que aujourd'hui et
bien finalement
certains critiques que ce soit tenue de
ce scrutin se soit tenue il ya un débat
qui fait que la proposition un peu
divisé oui d'un côté c'est très
important le commerce l'administration
la politique il faut soutenir il faut
continuer il faut maintenir le lien là
sans trop perdre mais de l'autre côté
évidemment il ya le départ de la santé
oms ne devrait pas sortir s'il n'a pas
absolument besoin de sortir et ça s'est
su on ne devrait pas et même si les
portiers partis politiques parfois aussi
fondé des grand faits d assemblement on
se demande encore pourquoi ça se passe
sans masque mais oui la population est
perturbé c'est vrai et la question
autour de la sortie sytral aujourd'hui
dé forcer les gens à sortir pour voter
peut-être on aurait pu faire c'est une
autre manière c'est le timing n'était
pas bien il ya aussi les nouveaux
variants à dudu coronavirus qui vit qui
viennent finalement augmenter les
contaminations c'est le cas aussi au
portugal c'est quoi c'est le vario
anglais qui contamine le plus silva riom
anglais qui vient d'afrique du sud c'est
ça et il ya aussi maintenant le mariant
brésilien n'a pas la porte
et peut-être on devrait commencer à
fermer les portes à l'ayraultport je
veux dire à ce que les liaisons sont
encore importantes entre le portugal et
le brésil en fait pas le brésil comme
vous le savez c'était l'ancien colonies
et je crois que le brésil c'est le pays
dans lequel les portugais voyage de
puces est un des pays où il ya de plus
de tourisme comme ils ont la même langue
pour la même culture et partage ont
passé ensemble qui fait un lien qui
aujourd'hui et sociale donc commercial
alors la communication du gouvernement
du propre aveu du premier ministre
antonio casta elle n'a pas toujours été
parfaite qu'est ce qu'on lui reproche
aujourd'hui au gouvernement dans cette
situation
on lui reproche aujourd'hui comme vous
dites parfois il fait un argument dans
une direction et après il est très
capable de tourner tout ça et il est
présenté sa d'une autre manière la
semaine prochaine il
il parle formidable orateur
c'est vrai mais on sait pas très bien ce
qui se passe derrière les rideaux
le portugal est moins con ce torrent de
la france et ses instances chez que ça
rend les gens étaient confortables il ya
un manque de confort remet en confiance
en moi cette manque de transparence des
conséquences et là des conséquences sur
la manière dans lequel les gens en
confiance en leur gouvernement et cette
confiance aujourd'hui elle est alors il
est pas alors vous êtes psychologue
clinicienne est ce que cette épidémie
finalement est elle elle joue sur le
moral des portugais ce que vous
constatez finalement de plus en plus de
dépression ont dit que ça peut être
aussi ça la troisième va bien
aujourd'hui ça peut être aussi ça c'est
tout à fait correct que tout le monde
est touché par cette idée me est ce que
je vois souvent aussi cessé dans les
familles qu'il ya des problèmes à garder
les enfants à la maison à faire tout
fonctionné comme ça devrait faire et les
symptômes au monde commence petit à
petit à s'accumuler les enfants si c'est
pas les annuler de ces des enfants parce
que c'est comme ça dans une unité où
vous avez plusieurs personnes on est
tous indépendants l'un de l'autre et le
symptôme est portée malheureusement les
enfants ça c'est en voit ça et chez les
patients en général sécurité qui fait
qu' on est un ferme et on n'a pas le
droit de sortir quelque part on est
aussi enfermé dont soi même on a du mal
à s'en sortir et ça fait que
oui les problèmes qu'il peut être dans
le passé étaient minimales
aujourd'hui commence tout à coup on
prend des dimensions difficile à gérer
parce que c'est vrai un petit problème
c'est tombé un autre comme un petit jeu
de dieu - domino attendre le prochain
tome 3 ans et on sait pas tout ça finit
assez correcte société comme avec mes
racines
merci pour votre témoignage plein on en
est en direct ce matin sur rtl france je
le rappelle vous êtes psychologue
clinicienne à lisbonne au portugal
x